so let's talk a little bit about credit
and lending so when I talk about credit
I'm literally just talking about
someone's willingness to lend you money
or to actually lend you money you've
heard of a credit card when you buy
something with a credit card essentially
the credit card issuer is lending you
the money to make that purchase and
you're gonna have to pay that back at
some future date likely with interest
likely with a lot of interest now
there's a lot of different types of
loans or credit you can get and they're
going to have different costs associated
with them you're like well what's the
cost of a loan well sometimes there's
just an outright fee associated with it
but more likely or on top of that the
interest that you pay on a loan is how
much you pay so if you're paying two
percent interest for a loan you're
paying a lot less per dollar on that
loan than if you had to pay say 20 or 30
percent interest and that might not seem
like a lot the difference between two
and twenty percent it's a ginormous
difference if you've watched our videos
on compound interest if you're paying 20
interest or even 10 interest and if
you're not paying down that bounce
pretty quickly that could end up being a
lot a lot of money you could very easily
end up paying a lot more in interest
than the initial amount of money that
you actually borrowed now what are the
scenarios we're going to pay less or
when you're going to pay more well we
have whole videos on your credit score
and the better your credit score in
general the better a risk you look like
you are to the lender and so you're
going to have to pay a lower rate a
lower interest rate which is a good
thing now above and beyond that there's
different types of loans there's loans
where if you aren't able to pay it back
the person who lent you money are still
they're still going to be able to get
something so for example if you take out
a mortgage to buy a house that's a loan
and you have a down payment and if you
aren't able to pay it back for whatever
reason the bank will foreclose and will
take the house and then they are likely
to sell the house in order to get their
money back so there's some risk for the
bank still they have to go through all
the trouble for closing on the house
maybe property value values go down
that's one of the reasons why they give
me also make you put a down payment that
also protects them a little bit but it's
a lot lower risk than if they didn't if
they weren't able to get access to that
house and so there you're going to have
to pay lower interest similarly a car
higher risk than a house so you're
probably going to have to pay a higher
interest for a car loan but if you don't
pay the bank will take the car and then
sell the car at the other end of the
spectrum I talked a little bit already
about credit cards you're just buying
stuff and if the if you don't pay back
it's going to be bad for you the bank
will really they'll report to the credit
credit bureaus and it's going to hurt
your credit score and future people
aren't going to lend to you or they're
going to charge a lot more to lend but
from the bank's point of view it's
pretty risky and so that's why they
likely charge much higher interest and
that interest can easily be in the teens
or even 20s even up to 30 percent in
certain situations and that is a lot of
interest and that's why in other videos
we talk about maybe paid on your credit
card balances as quickly as possible and
then there's things even more extreme
things like payday loans which I don't
recommend anyone watching this video use
those are usually lenders to some degree
taking advantage of people pretty
desperate for money where they're out of
money they need 500 they go to these
payday lenders and they say okay we'll
give you 500 but pay us 550 in three
days
when you get your paycheck for some
folks that might not feel like a lot
okay it's an extra fifty dollars but if
you actually think about that as an
annual interest rate I have a whole
video on that it's actually a ginormous
interest rate and if someone does that
consistently and it's obviously not a
great cycle to be in uh you could end up
paying a lot more to these payday loan
lenders uh than than you suspect so the
big picture is credit can be a useful
thing off maybe you're making an
investment you're buying real estate you
need a place to live you're buying a
house you need a car these are all
reasonable things and it is okay even
sometimes to potentially borrow for
consuming things things that you enjoy
but I would be a little bit more a lot
more careful with that but the key
takeaway is the bigger a risk you are
the more that you're likely to pay for
that loan